bah
pour pour nous normalement la saison
elle commence là maintenant avril mais
il ya beaucoup de touristes qui arrivent
et a énormément d'étrangers est
normalement c'est la saison mais là on
peut pas ouvrir entre rien fait on on
est on est obligé de rester fermés en
attente ou simplement l'espace aérien
les touristes qui revient en tunisie
l'année 2020 est foutu pour nous parce
que 1 des touristes ils vont pas revenir
du jour au lendemain suite au profit de
19 donc on est obligé d'attendre on est
obligé d'appeler
[Musique]
dépassé par d'autres clients avant la
guerre du golfe des attentats
terroristes etc et on arrivait à avoir
une n'était pas agréé totale et brutale
de l'activité avait un petit peu de
visibilité et puis possibilité de
reprise alors que là on n'a pas de
visibilité du tout on sait pas combien
de temps ça va durer
donc ça va dépendre de quand les vols
vont être en reprendre donc parfois on
parle de juillet ou août septembre on
sait pas pour être réaliste 2020 s'est
penché perdu on pense beaucoup plus de
1100 m
faut par contre pour les mesures de
soutien économique et social pour le
secteur on n'est pas content du tout
l'état n'a pas la capacité de mettre sur
pied un chômage partiel
la seule mesure qui a été fait pour le
mois d' assez que l'état accord que il
ya une demande de l'entreprise pour ses
employés 200 dinars donc environ 70
euros
mais c'est loin de ce qu'on aurait
souhaité elle aurait aimé report des
échéances fiscales sociales donc ça n'a
pas été la corpiq
l'idée qui co qui est quand même en
train d'avancer pour laquelle on est
plutôt optimiste ses clips et a même
surpris et d'une ligne de crédit
spécifique au secteur touristique hôtels
et restaurants